>> Laura: SENATE JUDICIARY
MEMBERS ARE PRESSING SUSAN RICE
TO EXPLAIN AN EMAIL.
>> TALKING ABOUT HER
CONVERSATION ON JANUARY THE
FIFTH WITH A PRESIDENT,
REASSURING HERSELF AND I GUESS
THE PRESIDENT THAT THIS WOULD BE
DONE BY THE BOOK.
I THINK THAT'S ODD OR DISTURBING
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
INVESTIGATION REGARDING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS ANYTHING BY
THE BOOK.
>> Laura: THE EMAIL INDICATES
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MAY
HAVE WITHHELD INFORMATION FROM
THE TRUMP TEAM, MEANWHILE THERE
IS NEW INFORMATION ON MICHAEL
FLYNN'S GUILTY PLEA, WHO BETTER
TO EXPLAIN A TALL THIN FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR EDDIE
McCARTHY WHO JOINS US FROM
NEW YORK.
I HAVE BEEN DYING TO TALK TO YOU
I HAVE BEEN DYING TO TALK TO YO
YOU.
IT SEEMS LIKE SHE IS BACK, SHE
IS THERE TO SAVE HIM ON BENGHAZI
IS THERE TO SAVE HIM ON BENGHAZ
BENGHAZI, WHEN OUT TO LIE ABOUT
THE DEAL AND WHAT CAUSED THE
ATTACK.
NOW SHE IS BACK AGAIN AND WHAT
LOOKS LIKE A BEE WHY A EMAIL TO
HERSELF.
>> THERE ARE TWO INTERESTING
THINGS ABOUT IT, YOU WOULD THINK
AT THE VERY TAIL END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT ALWAYS DID
IT BY THE BOOK IT WOULDN'T BE
NECESSARY TO TELL PEOPLE THAT
THINGS NEEDED TO BE DONE BY THE
BOOK.
PARTICULARLY WHEN SENATOR GRAHAM
POINTS OUT THIS THING WAS
ANYTHING BUT DONE BY THE BOOK
UNLESS THE BOOK IS RULES FOR
RADICALS.
THEY DIDN'T IDENTIFY THE BOOK.
THE OTHER INTERESTING THING THAT
YOU POINT TO IS THIS HOLDING
OUT, LAYING THE GROUNDWORK TO
HOLD OUT INFORMATION.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTS TO KNOW
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS IF
THERE IS ANY REASON WHY WE CAN'T
SHARE WITH THE INCOMING TEAM,
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON THEN.
THEY WERE INVESTIGATING FLYNN AT
THAT TIME AND HE WAS GOING TO BE
SUSAN RICE'S SUCCESSOR WHO YOU
THINK SHE WOULD BE COOPERATING
WITH AND SHARING INFORMATION
WITH.
THEY WERE REGARDING HIM AS A
CRIMINAL SUSPECT, THINKING ABOUT
DOING A LOGAN ACT PROSECUTION ON
HIM WHICH IS ABSURD.
THEY ULTIMATELY HAD THE FBI GO
SPEAK TO HIM AND ENDED UP
PROSECUTING HIM FOR FALSE
STATEMENTS.
I WONDER IF THEY ARE LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK TO NOT LET HIM IN ON
THINGS BECAUSE THEY ARE
REGARDING HIM AS A SUSPECT
RATHER THAN A SUCCESSOR.
>> Laura: A FRIEND OF MINE
TODAY REMINDED ME OF ONE WE WERE
IN THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION,
USUALLY IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
YOU'RE NOT STILL SENDING EMAILS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME THAT
EMAIL DROPPED, WAS IT BEFORE
12:00 NOON -- WHAT WAS THE
TIMING OF THAT?
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEARING
OUT HER OFFICE, SHE IS GONE.
THIS IS A TRUMP LAND AFTER
12:00.
>> STILL USING GOVERNMENT EMAIL
AND I THINK SHE STILL HAD HER A
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
SHE IS CREATING A GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENT ON PURPOSE, WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE USUAL THING IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
OFTEN THEY TRY TO NOT CREATE
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS WHEN THEY
WERE DOING GOVERNMENT WORK.
SHE WAS MAKING A PAPER TRAIL
HERE.
>> Laura: WANT TO ASK YOU
QUICKLY ABOUT THIS DEAL WITH
ROBERT PORTER AND THIS WHOLE
THING WITH HIS EX-WIVES AND
ACCUSED OF ABUSE.
THE TIMELINE IT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INITIALLY SAID,
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THESE
SECURITY CLEARANCES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE STILL
WORKING IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WITHOUT SECURITY CLEARANCES --
IS THAT NORMAL?
>> IS NOT NORMAL FOR PEOPLE TO
BE WORKING AND AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT A FULL
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
THE WHITE HOUSE EVIDENTLY SAID
THE FBI INVESTIGATION WAS
CONTINUING.
IT LOOKS LIKE ACCORDING TO WHAT